thanks to Mack Weldon for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
what it's like doing a virtual depo
right now
if you're in Florida this is what you
look like because you're not wearing a
shirt because apparently they're not
wearing shirts in Florida because
Florida
[Music]
oh I didn't see you there
and set up a tripod and a camera in it
whole bunch of lights well since you're
here and we're all locked inside in this
never-ending Chekhov's winter this
prison of our own homes this panopticon
of social media and lockdown orders I
guess we might as well do a meme review
and since everyone loves lawyers and
coronavirus might as well combine
everyone's two favorite things together
yeah let's do a legal coronavirus meme
review meme review meme review trademark
of peopie all rights reserved as a
criminal lawyer what's the biggest issue
you're dealing with in 2020 trying to
figure out how to correctly turn on the
vacuum cleaner in the dishwasher oh man
it's it's been so interesting seeing how
the legal profession functions when
we're all working from home these days
it's been really interesting seeing that
a lot of the stuff that makes lawyers
expensive like going into court and
waiting there for hours just to have a
minor hearing can actually be
accomplished over video conferencing
software yeah trying to to work the the
vacuum cleaner in the dishwasher well
sometimes appearing in court can be can
be very difficult and apparently in
Florida they are appearing on video
conferences from home without shirts on
so all of you lawyers out there please
put a shirt on if you're showing up to
court put on a tie even if it's in your
own home no you can't approach the bench
if you have a cold Oh big mistake big
mistake he approached the judge without
asking for permission first you know
what happens when you approach the judge
without asking for permission entering
the well but this cartoonist screwed
that up because you wouldn't ask for
permission if you were already there
think about that
if you're experiencing the following
symptoms headache body aches shortness
of breath fever developed aches and
pains difficulty sleeping easily
frustrating can't communicate properly
feeling dizzy this is not the corona
virus these are the effects of being an
attorney oh boy that hits close to home
it can be tough being a lawyer out there
and look III know it's tough for
everyone these days but yeah lawyers
dealing with this stuff on a regular
basis cuz we work really really long
hours we'll work ten twelve hours a day
seven days a week often if we're
preparing for trial often people confuse
you know being a jerk with being a
disposition it's no it's actually it's
just a consequence of becoming a lawyer
you become a jerk and you get all the
aches and pains that give they go with
it so yeah I feel that what it's like
doing a virtual depo right now yeah as
you may know if you watch this channel a
deposition is questioning a witness
under oath and you'll have a
stenographer there taking down the the
words that are being spoken well you
can't do that now because you're within
six feet you're within the same room
you're you don't want to spread the
germs so what lawyers have taken to
doing is doing a virtual depo you are
having a video conference and the
witness is still under oath you have the
stenographer call in to the virtual depo
and maybe they're recording it for a
future posterity which is something that
it should do anyway and it drives me
insane that they don't record these
things often it should be recorded you
should be able to refer back to without
having to refer to the transcript from
the stenographer but anyway if you're in
Florida this is what you look like
because you're not wearing a shirt
because apparently they're not wearing
shirts in Florida because Florida
divorce lawyers in April after two week
corrode a virus Koren sees you consider
yourself lucky if you have a significant
other to spend the quarantine with and
and you come out stronger at the end of
the quarantine government orders
non-essential workers to work from home
lawyers somehow our social workers oh
well look especially you have to imagine
district attorneys and
public defenders certainly essential
workers and you know as I mentioned in
another video the prisons are being hit
really really hard by coronavirus
because you can imagine everyone is
forced to being in confinement and we're
hearing numbers of like eighty ninety
and a hundred percent infection rates in
some prisons it's a really really bad
time for lawyers for prison guards for
judges for district attorneys public
defenders it's not really a laughing
matter
I mean you know I feel it it's it's it's
tough for everyone but you know life has
to go on the wheels of the judicial
system have to go on mid nineteen
turning lawyers into cavemen last day
before
oh poor Matthew Perry oh remember
bath.you Perry he was a he was a
good-looking guy yeah
but I I am trying to work out but I I
think I'd be able to be leaving lockdown
with a few extra coronavirus pounds it's
just hard like not leaving the house
going on maybe one walk I think I went
outside a couple days ago that was that
was a good time I feel like we're all at
home doing nothing but sitting around
and drinking mr. Pibb and red vines and
talking about friends alum Matthew Perry
you know this would be more fun with a
friend I got an idea hey are you doing
anything right now yeah somebody set up
a tripod in a camera in my family room
you want to react to some legal memes
cool I'll send you the zoom link okay
it's working you're frozen yeah why
don't you try and log in again okay know
what what yeah try it again no I can't
hear you can you hear me alright alright
day seven of quarantine attorneys let's
argue I want to feel something oh man I
I really feel that I feel this deep for
two reasons
firstly I live my housemates are lawyers
and so we like get our arguing to
another level like there is no playing
around when it comes to like who hasn't
done the dishes cuz we are ready to like
moved do people ever talk to you and say
like I'm really
good at arguing therefore I should go to
law school
people don't say it to me because I
don't think I am like in real life I'm
the most non confrontational person so I
actually don't argue a lot but like you
know when you've kind of been in not an
argument but you like when you've kind
of fallen out with a friend and then you
stand in the shower later listening to
emotional Adele music and you think of
all the things you could have said in
that moment maybe this isn't as
relatable with the adult place but kind
of like when you come away from like an
argument or a confrontation and you
think of all the arguments you could
have made and that's when I knew I'd be
a good lawyer because I was like you see
lawyers don't have to be super
confrontational person because they can
do all that preparation beforehand and
turn up with all of that arguments in
their pristine golden shiny form family
religion friendship these are the three
demons you must slay if you want to
succeed in big lot oh it's true
ya like it it's true like I agree how
would you say your life has changed
under the Damocles of the coronavirus
and and being forced to the lockdown are
you are you less social or more social
than working normal hours at the firm
that is a really hard one because so I
trained with a lot of other trainee
lawyers my own age and like we often go
out for coffee together and we lunch
together and I really liked that and now
I'm just like so stir crazy because I
don't have someone to just like break
out and talk to you so I'm probably more
antisocial but I'm outside a lot more
which sounds kind of depressing but I
often think it's very easy when you're
working at a law firm that you will just
be inside all day unless you make the
active effort to like go and get coffee
or like go and eat lunch out you won't
leave like you won't leave and so now
I'm like taking as many like walks as I
can today
oh speaking of billable hours I think
this is pretty funny it's just like how
the level of desperation gets more and
more like as we're getting further into
the crisis yeah and and I guess some
background here in big firms lawyers get
a salary but in order to get that salary
which is
really pretty good for people that are
just coming out of law school or college
you have to work an insane amount of
hours and those are called billable
hours and at least in the u.s. like the
very bottom floor would be probably
about 2,000 billable hours and if you're
a first or second year it's probably
more like 2,300 billable hours and
that's just hours that you can build to
a client it's not the actual hours that
you work in the firm which is often like
50% more than that so you might be
working like 3 or 3,000 or 3500 hours to
get 2,000 or 2,300 billable hours I also
think it's really interesting and I
didn't realize this before I started how
closely you have to record that time oh
yeah right my timesheets are so detailed
and I had no idea that that like I have
no idea what happened so to give also to
give context every single task I do per
day I have to record by the minute
because then when the firm wants to
charge a client they have to turn around
and say this is exactly what we spent
time on so you know exactly what you're
gonna pay for but that means that like
every hour of the like when I first
started I found it really stressful
because I was kind of like do I stop my
time as if I go to the toilet like it
was just like really intense yeah well
it depends on if you're thinking about
the clients in in the bathroom or not
which I wasn't I did keeping keeping up
with the billable requirement here yeah
the the bonus in terms of toilet that I
feel like that's an American thing
were there shortages of toilet paper in
gravy oh my god you have no idea people
weren't so crazy like we definitely we
had it here as well and the funniest
thing is like I walk past a supermarket
the same supermarket every day to the
firm and every morning there would be
like lines of people holding their
toilet paper and it would be sold out by
like 10 minutes past opening and I was
like I like it we'll get back in stock
it did not get back in stock like UK
wife helped five weeks and I was like oh
my god like okay I actually run out so
unnecessary
yeah and it's not I don't see why the
coronavirus would like make people use
more toilet paper but I guess I think
maybe this is TMI but I'm on I've been
on a team but a for for a long time so
doesn't really affect me as much as
everybody else and also I love how
extreme people were getting they were
like obviously like BuzzFeed and
companies like that were like jumping on
the bandwagon like here's how you can
make toilet paper out of like organic
leaves and I'm like I don't want Evan I
don't want it to get to that level okay
can we just not stockpile that's an easy
solution yeah
oh my god let's not spend too much time
on the toilet paper here receiving
deliveries during pandemic like leave it
on the doorstep and get back here but
you know what I actually think it's the
other way around someone delivered a
parcel yesterday and I opened the door
and the man like he'd only just put it
down and he looked up at me and he like
like ran backwards like almost fell over
his feet and then he was like oh like I
need to take a photo to prove it's being
delivered so I stood by my parcel and I
was like I feel now obliged to pose so I
stood that with my parcel like thank you
and he was like I only needed a picture
of the parcel I didn't need a picture of
wait photo of me and a parcel on a
database somewhere like I think that
means you're spending too much time on
Instagram I think you need to step back
from the influencer lifestyle just a
little bit like yes
switched on skinny arm out in front and
posing with the parcel yeah I am
thanking my delivery people like they
are soldiers returning from war i
they're really making our lives
I think livable at this point so I'm
thankful is Joe exotic a thing in the UK
like is is Tiger King making rounds
around there so much thing to the extent
which three nights ago I was like maybe
I want a mullet and then I was like no I
don't
you may not have a choice we're all
cutting our own hair these days so you
may end up with one no matter what yeah
I might slip and then just have to
become my energy exhausted although
maybe I'm like more of a Carol Baskin
I've not decided yet
maybe I'm one of the Tigers who knows
yeah are you team gel or a team Carol oh
definitely team Carol because and I love
how people work I was like people are
kind of like Carol is like on Twitter
people were like Carol is so crazy like
she's you know she potentially like
murdered her ex-husband and all this
sort of thing and I'm like yeah but like
he he literally keeps 200 tigers in his
like land estate in the middle of
America I'm like how are we normalizing
that already well I mean yeah I mean
technically Carol had had lions and
tigers as well but you know between the
two of them one of them is spending two
decades in federal prison and the other
is a free person so I'm not sure who we
should be giving the benefit of the
doubt to here this is true and I
actually didn't think about that the guy
I I would love to meet him imagine being
his lawyer I just think that would be so
is so incredible all right working in
the office home home no this speaks
sorry on a deep level I won't lie so at
the moment all of our internal meetings
are the fun are done with like by camera
like everyone's like on camera like us
on this soon and so you kind of feel
obliged to look like somewhat not asleep
but then equally you're like but I'm in
my own home and it's like a very other
start some people was like everyone was
still wearing business wire at the style
and I was like I'm in my own home like
I'm not putting on a suit like I don't
know what's happening and it's like
regressed and regressed and regressed
and now I'm just turning up in my
t-shirt like take me or leave me have me
for who I am yeah in Florida apparently
they are having trouble with the
attorneys who were showing up on the
zoom calls without shirts on and you
know sometimes you can get away with
wearing less formal stuff below but I've
never heard it well I mean it makes
total sense in Florida that they would
show up in front of the judge
video conference call with opposing
counsel no shirt no shirt okay so here's
the difference I that I know in the UK
that we have now opened up that tool
courts as well and I'm a hundred percent
sure if I was in like any kind of like
judicial situation like that I would be
in full black business way graduating
law school like I am never going to
financially recover oh no I god I had so
much law school day I had so much law
school debt please tell me that you
incurred a whole bunch of debt as well
okay so I did financial and emotional
debt but I will say I'm pretty sure law
school fees in America
oh boy higher than the UK so I kind of
don't want to complain too much because
I'm still in debt don't get me wrong but
like I don't think it's near the level
of the states more or less than the
equivalent of two hundred thousand
dollars like more or less than two
hundred thousand times
dammit I'm like under 25% of that for
four years I probably owed around thirty
thirty to forty thousand pounds and
you're not even gonna be a real lawyer
doing litigation at the end of that I
feel so bad we're gonna pull out I'm
ready I am ready for us to fall out that
would be the ultimate head-to-head we're
gonna come back for round two and I'm
gonna have arguments I just do a wide
transactional know them better than this
edges lawyers where can the people find
you on the internet so come along with
me on my youtube channel you can also
find me on instagram on twitter under
the same handles beep Cornwell why did
that feel like an interview I'm like
well thank you Eve so much and thank you
for providing some human contact in
these really terrible times thank you so
much for having me bye
oh that was fun interacting with people
was fun I missed that
no well more memes stop spreading stupid
rumors about martial law completely
false we will continue closing her this
is not martial law this fall on NBC
martial law so this is this is a pet
peeve of mine its martial law spelled ma
AR TI al as in like an army a martial
army not martial like marshallmatters
though I would I would totally watch
that show martial law and then you have
a crossover with ice-t from Law & Order
now that that's been canceled justice
I mean NBC make this show make martial
law that would be amazing
motion to cancel the rest of the year
motion granted motion granted ah moved
to strike
the previous portion of this year - man
screw this year dear council by opening
up this email you've agreed to accept
electronic service and stipulated that
our motion for summary judgment will be
unopposed stay same so this is another
thing that lawyers have to deal with
except under these extenuating
circumstances you have to physically
mail almost everything or personally
deliver motions or discovery requests
and you have to physically file the
stuff with the court I've never
understood except for sort of
traditional reasons why this is now that
everyone can't really go to court
although some people still have to
physically file stuff with the court we
should be able to do what's called
provide things via like electronic
service and accept service
electronically in this day and age it's
so much better and it's so much more
certain that if you send it via email or
like if you have a read receipt with an
email that's way better than personally
handing this stuff with the process
server or sending it through the mail
although you get crazy stuff like this
where you say if you open the email you
agree to accept service and and grant my
motion for summary judgment it's Connor
that part will not work but the other
stuff should work and we should just do
away with with having non electronic
service it's nonsense
quarantine protein if you run out of
toilet paper that copy of the motion to
compel you received from opposing
counsel will suffice that is true
because when opposing counsel gives you
a motion to compel it's garbage and it
should go in the toilet paper if I send
a motion to compel meritorious and
cannot be used for toilet paper
sadly my side hustle is just billing
more hours yeah
it's been a while since I've been in the
big firm world I was in there for a
decade and yeah when you're in big firm
world your side hustle is just more of
your main hustle so I'm glad that I
don't have to do that anymore and now I
have my own practice I know people
always speculate that I'm not actually
wearing pants but I do actually wear
pants when I record these videos like
the pants that I'm wearing right now are
from Mac Weldon they are Mac Wheldon's
radius pants and they're incredibly
comfortable and they're the perfect
pants for this post-apocalyptic Cove is
19 stay at home situation because they
look like real pants but they're
actually athleisure pants that are
incredibly comfortable you can do
anything in them because if you have to
be stuck at home you should wear Mac
Weldon Mac Weldon for the man that wants
to look like they're wearing pants but
doesn't have to and these pants are even
more comfortable because I'm pairing
them with Mac Walden's famous boxer
briefs which are so comfortable but
obviously I can't show you that but well
yeah highly recommended because if
you're watching this channel you're
probably an adult and you deserve to
have some nice underwear Mac Weldon is a
men's essential clothing company that
focuses on smart design and premium
fabrics to make some of the most
comfortable clothing out there
I've ordered Mac Weldon with my own
money for years and it's especially
great in these times when I can go
online and I can order Mac Weldon
straight from their website order as
many options and sizes as I want have
them delivered and then return anything
that doesn't fit or I don't like free of
charge and if you want to try out their
underwear you don't have to even return
it because nobody wants to use used
underwear so if you would like to try
Mac Weldon get 20% off all you have to
do is go to Mac Weldon calm
league illegal or use the promo code
legal eagle at checkout also drop a link
in the doobly-doo as well clicking on
the link really helps out this channel
and what's great is Mac Walton has a
loyalty program where if you sign up you
can get 20% off indefinitely for all of
your future orders and get access to new
stuff when it comes out so do you agree
with my analysis do you disagree with
Eve's analysis leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other meme
reviews and reactions to the crazy
things on reddit and social media and
crazy posts on Facebook just click on
this link and I'll see you in court